all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we have a lot to unpack in this
video so let's just get straight into it
so what this does here is this picks up
with two things that have happened in
Marvel Comics one is a really long time
ago and another one is relatively
recently as far as the relatively recent
event goes at the time this story was
created it's an event called The War of
Kings now dwarf Kings is a story that
we've never actually covered here on
Comics explained I'd like to I think
it's a really really cool story the
overall gist of this is that you
basically had the Shia Empire which was
taken over by Vulcan Gabriel Summers the
third brother of Cyclops that we didn't
know about he's just this really
overpowered Omega Level mutant he
conquered an entire Empire took it over
and then went to war with the cree
Empire Now by that point in time the
Inhumans from Earth had actually
traveled to the Korean Empire and they
had taken it over so in effect the war
of Kings was a war between Black Bolt
and Vulcan and what this did is it
actually led to a giant bomb that was
detonated and when that happened it
basically ripped a hole in space and
time creating what was called a Fisher
and that basically led to the cancer
verse that Universe was explored in a
story called The Thanos imperative which
we have covered here on Comics explained
and that story is amazing but the thing
about this is that in the midst of all
that Black Bolt was believed to have
been dead in the sense that it was
believed he was caught in the explosion
what had actually happened is blackbolt
had basically been ripped away from the
main Marvel Universe and into the cancer
verse he once subdued by one of the many
angled ones which is basically what
Shuma gorath is in Marvel Comics except
and the instance of shimogorath he
basically Broke Free of the spaces
between universes which is where the
mini angled ones reside and he started
conquering whole realities but the ones
that took over the cancer verse are the
ones that are normally confined in the
space between universes but because of
the events of the cancer verse which
again at the end of this video you're
welcome to check out the playlist on the
Thanos imperative storyline they had
basically taken over that universe and
that's where Black Bolt ended up at so
of course he's able to overpower it and
then he ends up back in the main Marvel
Universe where he's rescued by the
inhuman teleporting dog lockjaw and
brought back to the Korea Empire right
brought back to the Inhumans themselves
the other thing that goes on here which
is a little bit bigger than this deals
with the Supreme intelligence directly
and the idea is that the Supreme
intelligence had at one point in time
come to the idea that if the cree Empire
wants to take over different races and
ultimately conquer the universe the best
way to do it is to basically engineer
beings that can kind of stand in as
members of those races right so to
create a scroll who looks like a scroll
to create a human who looks like a human
so on and so forth but what would really
go on here is they would have what was
called an inhuman Gene and the reality
is they would undergo Terra Genesis and
when that happened they would develop
Powers but because they were engineered
by the cree they would be loyal to the
Creed but in effect what it would do is
it would allow the cree race to
basically create Trojan horses in these
different Empires and then take them out
from the inside out and so the idea
behind this is that where it was
initially a grand idea the Supreme
intelligence had a kind of vision that
the inhuman project would lead to the
destruction of the entire Cree race and
so what does Supreme intelligence did in
response to that is it ordered the
accuser Corps to destroy the entirety of
the inhuman project and all the
scientists involved with the project and
then to travel to every single world
where an inhuman was was stationed and
destroy that world right raise the whole
thing kill everyone there to make sure
that no inhuman escapes ultimately five
different worlds survived and that's
where you end up getting the wives of
Black Bolt coming from right they come
from those secret inhuman races that
survived and basically escaped this
great big huge Purge now beyond that
there did come a point in the Supreme
intelligence's history when it basically
had a kind of vision yet again that it
would ultimately be destroyed by black
bull of the Inhumans but the Creed
didn't know where Black Bolt was at they
didn't even know where the Inhumans were
they were just so well hidden from
seemingly everybody in the universe so
in order to make sure that the Supreme
intelligence survived what it did is it
placed inside of Ron and the accuser the
Supreme Court seat so that at a future
point in time the Supreme intelligence
could be reborn in its original form and
so what's really cool here and what goes
on and this is going to be one of the
more important things here this
basically leads to the return of the
Inhumans on Earth as we covered it in
the last video now when Black Bolt shows
up here of course he's greeted by the
different wives that are being presented
to him as a way to kind of unite the
inhuman City so this is one thing to
understand Medusa is his one true wife
him having these other wives is more
ceremonial than anything else but what
it does is it's kind of an official
recognition of these different tribes of
Inhumans by Blackpool right so you are
all now being brought under the attilan
royal family of the Inhumans by having a
quote unquote marriage to Blackboard
right so again it's more of a ceremonial
thing and so what this does is it
basically transitions back over to the
forever city of the high evolutionary
now remember this is one of the last
pieces of the puzzle we don't really
know exactly what these alternate
reality versions of Reed Richards are
building we just simply know they're
building something and so the thing
about this is that as they're uniting
all these different bits and pieces when
the Inhumans arrive back onto the scene
a giant War breaks now again this
conflict right this war is not only
among these alternate reality versions
of read but their forces which of course
include the mole man and different
people like that but it basically leads
to the main read Richards along with the
Future Foundation and the various
villains that they've unified in an
effort to find a way to destroy these
alternate reads joining into the
conflict as well so this right here is
basically the war of the four cities
this is the event that the future
version of Valeria warned her younger
self about right the war of the four
cities will come that you will have
these alternate versions of Reed that
will try to unite these different parts
of the world in order to basically
harness little bits of Machinery or
little things they need but it'll create
a massive conflict now in the middle of
all this of course you basically have
Black Bolt who arise Black Bolt does his
thing but also you have Medusa who
appears before the main Reed Richards
with lockjaw and teleports him to the
inhuman Royal City now you do get this
really really amazing moment that goes
on here where you have Doctor Doom again
who's part of the Future Foundation
facing off against these different
versions of Reed he is a able to
momentarily overcome one and it's really
kind of funny because like this guy's
like oh it's a Doctor Doom right because
this alternate version of read remember
they would travel around the Multiverse
they would capture different versions of
Doom and they would lobotomize it so
when it recognizes a Doctor Doom it
starts to ready the inhibitor collar and
of course Doom just slaps him across the
face right he's like do not speak again
unless it is to answer my questions do
you understand it's like the most Doctor
Doom thing ever he does have this
amazing moment in this story it's gonna
be absolutely awesome but before any of
that transpires he's actually overcome
by the different villains that were
unified to destroy the alternate
versions of reef now of course they try
to kill him with fire and it's just this
amazing moment right this is the moment
I was talking about it's like this
amazing moment Doctor Doom is like fire
you try to kill me with fire Folly I
have burned before World be damned Doom
endures and like literally just immersed
in flame stands up and goes to kill the
other villains and in fact he does he
kills one of them right on the spot
right just kills him right there this is
one of those things where like if you're
going to to betray Dr Doom well then my
friend you pay your money and take your
chances that's literally all it is man
that's literally how that works and
sometimes the slot machines do not fall
in your favor and that's literally what
happens here now the reality here and
really the biggest reason why the
Inhumans are here in the first place is
really kind of Jonathan Hickman sort of
hitting on things behind the scenes in
the sense that with the Illuminati and
all of that that Black Bolt and those
guys are basically allies specifically
Black Bolt is more of a close Ally to
Reed Richards so it's really showing up
here to help destroy the multiversal
version of Reed Richards write these
different versions of read from other
realities but one of the things to know
and what's really interesting here is
the desire of Reed Richards himself and
even Doctor Doom is to at least take one
of these guys prisoner because the
intention is that by doing so they'll be
able to gain valuable information what
are they building why are they doing
this right what's this massive threat
that they're talking about that they
keep having to face off against but the
idea of the Inhumans is to annihilate
these guys right destroy them be done
with it it's just one of those hardened
aspects of one of the different elements
between the humans than anybody else
being humans don't usually take
prisoners instead the Inhumans basically
destroy those that either try to bring
them harm or are a credible threat right
they just don't really take prisoners
they just annihilate everybody and so
what this does is it leads to two
versions of these Reeds being captured
by the Inhumans themselves now those two
Reeds will become incredibly important
over the course of this video the third
one actually ends up escaping but in
fact its Escape is noticed by Dr Doom
who travels into to find that version of
read only to find himself overcome by
read and in fact it's really intriguing
here because this version of read
literally says do you have or really ask
like do you have any idea how many times
I fought you in different universes how
many other you's I've defeated
single-handedly right like while your
origin and the role you play in
different universes is relatively unique
from one Universe to the next your mad
quest for power is always the same your
level of power is for the most part
consistent if I can defeat you there I
can defeat you here and he literally
starts doing dances right just like just
playing games around Doctor Doom all the
way to the point that he manages to slap
one of the inhibitor callers on Doom
himself now again we saw from like the
Council of Reed's Stories the inhibitor
collars are used to lobotomize Doom
right to literally destroy higher brain
function and reduce them to a base fate
there's no real way to restore someone
after the caller's done its job and
destroyed higher brain function there's
no way to bring them back and so
literally he tells Doom that right like
you know exactly how these collars work
you've been told how these collars work
right like Reed Richards of this
universe of this Earth he explained it
to you and when Doom's like yes then the
response to this version of read is then
you will do exactly what I tell you to
otherwise I will activate this collar I
will destroy your higher brain function
and you'll spend the rest of your days
drinking your food through a straw take
me to latviria and so what this does is
it basically leads to what's in effect
the conclusion of this battle right it's
really more of a battle as opposed to
like a giant War but at the end of the
day it all kind of comes to a conclusion
right it all basically winds down and
ends the Ascension engine is basically
deactivated or kind of shut down to a
degree and so the result of this is that
Spider-Man and Nathaniel Richards and
Reed Richards are basically brought
before What's called the door of eldrach
right basically belonging to the
Inhumans this guy was a human at one
point in time when he went to the
terrigen Miss he just turned into a
giant door I know it's weird right like
it's just one of those wonky things just
go with it but the idea is that the door
only ever is based on one of two things
either need or desire and which one that
is depends on what Universe you're in in
this reality the door of eldrak focuses
on desire and so the reality is that
once Reed and Nathaniel and Peter Parker
basically pass through the door the door
will take them to where they desire to
be most even if they don't even realize
they desire to be there right if it's
like a subconscious desire the one that
is the most significant that's where the
door will take them now the funny thing
about this is the questions asked by
Peter can the door take you through time
if what Peter desires most is to go back
and save the life of Uncle Ben will the
door send him there none of them really
know the only way to find out is to walk
through the door which is exactly what
they do now again while this is taking
place there are a couple things going on
in the background that we haven't quite
covered yet and we'll cover them here
that when Black Bolt had taken over the
cree Empire he is in effect the emperor
right he's the king he's the ruler the
top guy but when he left what he did is
he put Ron and the accuser in charge as
kind of a steward a person keeping an
eye on the kingdom while Black Bolt is
away and so what it did is it put Ronin
in a position where those individuals
who were still loyal to the cree
Heritage or the cree Empire and believe
that the Inhumans are unjust rulers they
actually appeal to Ronin and they
basically say you should be the one
running the Kingdom right now you should
be the one running the show not the
Inhumans the Inhumans have vacated their
position this leaves the entirety of the
cree Kingdom open for you will you take
it or will you will you leave it and
ultimately Ron and the accuser speaks
directly with Crystal of the Inhumans
now Crystal of the Inhumans was always
kind of a bit of an outlier like she was
part of the inhuman royal family but she
was more of like a person who orbited
the family as opposed to a tried and
true member I mean she was but she
wasn't she had a thing going on with
like Quicksilver for a little while and
in fact Crystal and Quicksilver have a
daughter which is kind of cool but the
idea behind Crystal being here is that
in order to solidify the rule of the
Inhumans over the creek that a marriage
was arranged between Crystal and Ronin
now the thing about this is that Ronin
was very much in love with Crystal but
the thing about Crystal is she saw the
marriage as more of a political game
than anything else which of course was
sort of distraught Ronin because in
reality it just kind of felt like she
wasn't actually into it for him she was
into it for the politics over time she
genuinely has developed a love for Ron
and the accuser but the thing about this
is that with him talking to her her
response is they're right right like the
Inhumans have vacated their throne even
if they don't know it if they wanted to
stay in charge of the cree Empire they
should have stayed with the cree Empire
the reality is that you are the rightful
ruler of the cree race because you're
their accuser right you're the top
person outside of the Inhumans Beyond
them you're the number one dog if you
want the kingdom take the kingdom and
that's literally what Ron and the
accuser does does at that point he
starts creating battle formations he
organizes the Armada with the intention
of traveling to Earth and eradicating
not just the Inhumans but the entirety
of the Earth's population but the other
thing that goes on here is that when
Nathaniel Richards passed through the
portal he ended up in Liberia where you
had that alternate version of Reed and
Doctor Doom this is where he basically
had to be right this is where he needed
to be and the thing about this is that
it's It's Kind of a Funny situation
because this alternate version of Reed
asked Nathaniel is the great hunt still
ongoing and the response of Nathaniel is
no I won the great hunt right I came out
on top now the thing about this and
we'll find out more about the great hunt
in a future story what's so ironic about
this is that this version of read the
reason why These Guys these alternate
reads even created and joined the
Council of reads in the first place the
reason why they were able to abandon
their own families is because their
fathers abandoned them right the sins of
the father become the sins of the son
and so for the most part the great hunt
was literally this multiversal hunt
among all these different versions of
Nathaniel and in fact we'll talk more
about that because this actually invokes
the entire role of like immortus King
the Conqueror all that stuff right it's
really really cool how it works but
again with this version of Nathaniel
saying you come out on top the response
of this version of read is well then
there's only one thing left to do right
like his intention is to basically
destroy Nathanael because his belief is
that Nathaniel is here for Doctor Doom
when in reality Nathaniel says like you
know sometimes it amazes me Reid it
seems like it's smart and as intelligent
as you are in every Universe you just
don't have the ability to read the room
right I'm not here for Dr Doom I'm here
because you need me and that's what's so
cool right that's what's so interesting
of course Peter Parker had basically
been teleported to Ben Grimm and told
Ben Grimm stop slulking over the fact
that doctor do enjoying the Fantastic
Four it's time for you to go home man
like go back to the Fantastic Four team
go join them now from here we jump back
to Ron and the accuser and what's really
interesting is again Ron and the
accusers on a quest to basically restore
the cree Empire back to the way it was
before and delete a campaign against
Earth but in order to do that he has to
restore the Supreme intelligence this is
where those two Reeds and the supremacy
that I told you about would become
incredibly important because what
happens is that when the cree Armada
shows up to Earth into the inhuman Royal
City or really to attilan itself they're
cloaked they're undetected no one knows
they're there they send a kind of
stealth vessel to the inhuman City
itself and they capture these two
versions of Reed and what Ronin does is
he literally puts them on trial and
judges against them right he's like as
the accuser I accuse you of hubris on
the most extreme level on a multiversal
level you have put your wants and
desires above all beings in the
Multiverse and as mortal men it's not
your role to do that I judge you and I
find you guilty now most people that I
judge would be annihilated they would be
destroyed and that would be the end of
it the truth is that your sacrifice will
have some measure of meaning you will
continue to live on and what Ronin does
is he releases the supremacy which
attaches itself to both versions of Reed
and then absorbs them into its own
Consciousness and restores the Supreme
intelligence it's kind of gruesome when
that happens the Supreme intelligence is
filled in on various things by the by
Ron and the accuser and it realizes with
us being here on Earth being humans
right Black Bolt is the one that I
dreamed of at some some previous point
in time blackbald Indian humans have to
die everybody on earth needs to be
eradicated now the funny thing about
this and this is what's so interesting
here is Jonathan Hickman kind of teasing
the events of like inhumanity and all
that kind of stuff because while the
Fantastic Four came before the events of
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers what we know is that during
that story The inhuman royal family were
not the only Inhumans on Earth that
there were various individuals walking
around the world who possess the inhuman
gene they simply hadn't been exposed to
the terrigen mist and they just didn't
know it now so this is him kind of
hitting at this idea there's a lot more
in humans roaming around Earth than we
were initially led to believe and that's
why the Supreme intelligence makes a
decision everybody's gotta go right like
they all Gotta Die and that's basically
the end of it and so with this Armada
based basically being formed right being
you know kind of coming together what we
find out is that when Ben Grimm was on
his way back to Earth he basically
reached out to the X-Men the Avengers
and the mighty Avengers he reached out
to the entirety of the superhero
landscape and it basically brought them
to Reed Richards and then read of course
apologize to everybody and is saying
look with everything that was going on
with these different alternate reality
versions of myself and so on and so
forth I should have reached out to all
of you first I should have come to all
of you first right we have fought side
by side against a multitude of threats
and while the different threats that we
Face depending on their severity may or
may not involve The Avengers or the
X-Men or the Fantastic Four the reality
is that this does it was foolish of me
to believe I could handle all of this on
my own and as friends I should have come
to you and so that's what he says I'm
coming to you now this war of the four
cities that we have right this massive
conflict is taking place something big
is coming something big is going to
happen and when it does I'm going to
need all of you for that now fortunately
for Reed he's kind of beat to the punch
because while the group is assembling
and while they're traveling out to deal
with these different versions of read
they literally look up into the sky and
they see the entire Cree Armada
descending on to the planet Earth with
the intention of eradicating everybody
now here's the crazy thing about this as
interesting as all of this is this Cree
Armada is going to be here for a little
while but a person is going to come
who's going to save the day and is going
to be amazing so from this point going
forward we start jumping back and forth
between the Future Foundation and the
Fantastic Four stories and let me tell
you something man this is when it gets
good right you guys remember Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers when you got
to like time runs out and like
everything was going nuts that's what
happens here with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace